yes so this talk is going to be about
how natural language processing motivate
white works and how deep learning is
work in the field I figured a lot of
people like to open their laptops and
take around or maybe contacts I
introduced so that the slides are also
at by it might get up if you like
I
could everyone read it
cool I see someone cool so it's going to
be about natural language processing and
how deep learning or how machine
learning in general is being used in in
processing language first I'm going to
motivate why why care why why do we care
about natural links processing and we're
over motivate why machine learning seems
such a good idea and it turns out that a
lot of the examples I will give there's
a specific algorithm being used which
are recurrent neural networks so the
second part is going to talk about how
we structure them and how they work and
finally I figured in this conference is
by data so a lot of people might not be
essence in machine learning but also in
Python and how we employ deploy models
so the third part will cover hey how do
we train this use case is going to be
google translator if you google you care
about 26 languages how do you train a
model if you Google and you care about
translation within a second how do you
make best difference
so we will use this gmail on our smart
phone it seems function before this is
what I find a good example of natural
Lynch boxing a friend might email you
and say hey Rob do you want to come over
for a barbecue this weekend and this
algorithm automatically proposes a reply
for you it says I found this in or it
says hey no sorry I'm not in for the
weekend
another example is the speech
recognition engine Siri by Apple who
your users see read Apple so what it
does is it if you could
okay more Google uses an apple using e
so another Melanie opposed to geotubes
you can say Siri show me the phone
number of my mom and it it will process
this queue and and and prompt me the
phone number of the person I asked for
another example of metronomes proxy we
do the question entry we can look at
images or we can look at other texts and
we can answer a question what colors are
the bananas and the algorithm the
natural language processing algorithm
will answer for us heaviest bananas are
green the fun thing about lasting is
that we're also going to cover attention
models and you can visualize it so this
algorithm somehow understands how we as
humans process language when we ask it
what is on the what what is the fur on
the cat's tail it will answer for it
will attend it will put attention
exactly on the cat still
and
you can also do recently actually this
you can read the story algorithms can
read stories and and answer questions on
top step
but the main focus for today in that
length processing is going to be machine
translation we care about translating as
English enters your French sentence this
is a fun image I found on the Microsoft
Research blog recently and where they
kind of show what what what deep
learning is doing in is machine
translation it kind of flattens and now
we are giving this this new deep
here this translation I care about and
then also to kind of orient us a bit
where where are we in the field of of AI
of machine learning this is this how I
see the world I mean you might have
different views but to kind of orient us
in this in all this algorithms machine
learning we have supervised learning
because we have data we have English and
French sentences we care about natural
language processing and deep learning is
going to be a tool for today I
also want to say that I want to make
this talk interactive yes in the end
there's 10 minutes for questions but if
at some moment you kind of lose my
explanation please raise your ass
so in all those examples I showed you so
far there's one overlapping theme
that all the recent innovations and all
the recent breakthroughs are made with
one specific algorithm which is
recurrent neural network so
this this part we will discuss how to
recur no network work what is in our
intuition for why they are used for
language and and
how do you record inaudible
so who here is familiar with normal
neural networks who here trained a
neural network before
cool so the governor get everyone on the
same line the neural network is inspired
of the brain where one neuron activates
another neuron activates another neuron
we might in put some we might have an
input say an image or text and then the
neurons in the end we say hey that might
be a class like cat or dog or in our
case an object or a subject or in the
sentence
we might also depict the neural also
will apply data this is the bear Python
code for a neural network we have an
input X we map that to hidden neurons to
hidden states H and we map that to an
output and our neural network is just
this basic lines of Python
we could also depict that in images so
we map one vector to a native atom to
another vector but now let's say we care
about classification of objects verbs
and subjects so in this our neural
network would say I as a subject cake is
a verb the ball is an object in the
second time this is we say the ball is a
subject roles is the verb and away is
the object
but something will not quite work in
here in the first case the ball was the
object and the neural network so would
would then classify this as an object
but here it is a subject so how would a
neural network distinguish between the
two and
that is where a recurrent neural network
comes in we can connect all these neural
networks over time because if the neural
network would have would have access to
classification is made before then it
can know it would learn hey if my
previous word was a verb that probably
this is an object and if I had no
previous word maybe then this might as
well be a subject
so we have lines between here
that is the recurrent neural network
again these are the equations but I
figured many more people here read
Python codes this is now the bare Python
code for a recurrent neural network the
difference is we are passing on this age
the hidden state now is an instance
variable of our recurrent neural network
cloths
quickly compare it so this is not a full
code but this is the the meaty part of
the code here we have we calculate this
age and age maps to the outputs yet in a
recurrent neural network information
recurs over time so we have a self of
age
so the cells the days of the old time
step and the input together make the new
cell the rates and death maps to be of
it a
recurrent neural network
so now this hidden state it will learn
we can we can frame this big neural
network and now this hidden state it
might propagate information hey this was
kind of a verb possibly this is an
object
here there's no input information so a
neural network might learn possibly over
probably this is a subject and
to show you that this is this is the
basic rigor neural network and it works
in there this is a clickable link if you
open the slide is a you can click on
this you will see an implementation of a
recurrent neural network a 112 lines of
Python code
we can already do powerful things with
this set up you can think about what
akka forecasting where you're inputting
input vectors about whether you want to
predict tomorrow's weather we can do
powerful things like detection in of
what a user is doing with the smart
phone is he running is he walking is he
taking the stairs so input vectors would
be the accelerometer data and output
would be walking I think two times over
the weekend I talked to people from the
financial markets in financial markets
we're actually interested in predicting
other stocks based on information from
one stock so input can be information
about some stock and output can be
information about another stock you see
the applications going
one thing that this model won't do for
us is that we
are kind of restricted that every added
every moment we have to make some
classification so input and output are
aligned
but if you think about it for machine
translation know start steering works if
I translate between English and Dutch
maybe but what now if I translate
between
English and Chinese
then there's no such an alignment of
input and output
so
we need to come up with a different
architecture of recurrent of a recurrent
neural network that deals with a
different sequence of inputs
words than a different sequence of
output words and that gets us to the
sexy shake architecture who hears in
ivory lace in second second four yeah it
reavie eights for sequence to sequence
because in our new architecture we care
about mapping an input sequence to an
output sequence and in this case the
recurrent network can work with any
length of of sequences now the input
sequence can be five tokens and the
output sequence can be four tokens
so then this first part we named at the
encoder it cares about encoding the
words of the input language and this
part we call it the decode we it cares
about
decoding the words of the output
language
so let's take take step back in in the
in the conversation we had so far what
did we do we I thought it with
motivating natural language processing
said natural Manx was going to give some
examples like
like the translation or the the Gmail
reply and then we said okay we're going
to look at recurrent neural networks
return on that first because they deal
they allow us to deal with machine
learning algorithms over time and now we
are extending that toward a sequence a
sequence architecture wherein we said we
spread out recur neural network up in an
encoder and a decoder parts and that way
we can work with input and output
sentences of different lengths
to this model I'm going to add one more
detail before we're going to continue in
how we do trainees models and the
problem is as follows let's say I have a
very very long as long as it sits on my
slides input sentence and I want to map
it to an output sentence maybe the input
sentence has kind of a special word or
has kind of a hard word now the
recurrent neural network will have a
hard time on remembering the specific
words maybe science fraud is it's a
Dutch it's that street name and it might
be hard for this recur no network to
encode so by the time we are translating
this French language or this French
sentence we might have forgotten about
what was tied strat
how would we solve this as humans what
would we do as humans if we were
translating this English language to a
French sentence we would peek back right
if by the time we are translating this
part of the functions we just speak back
at the input hey what were we
translating again I will continue our
translation and
a recurrent neural network can do that
too which we call attention
so if if the recursion or network could
give some cue to the encoder hey give me
again this this little piece of
information we we forgot the children
were playing but we didn't know which
ports they were playing again and we can
kind of peek back at the inputs so we
have encoded the words less than thought
you are Oh
and now we feedback at the input and we
see oh it was soccer well
give that given an input to me and then
I will now translate football or I don't
know if this is the correct French
translation but I
see someone laughing maybe it's not but
but you get the case that is attention
and when I do this for every time step
so this is our translation model
in a translate in our translation model
we have the encoder it takes in the
words of the input language and then as
soon as we feed the goat token it will
start decoding and at every time step it
gives a key to the encoder to ask for
more information
this is the full second check model with
the tension used for translation
you can also visualize it which is kind
of fun and then you you start
understanding how attention works you
kind of expect this linear because
English and friends are kind of the same
languages so you kind of expect the
linear behavior but the fun thing in
here is you see this friends of diagonal
stuff what we do in English is we put
the adjectives before the noun
what the French language does it has put
the adjectives after the noun and that
is this off-diagonal attention you see
officialized here but that's only a fun
thing we now understand the basic
algorithm or the algorithm this was
actually the algorithm used by Google
right I mean this is the algorithm for
that machine translation
the second part of the talk is going to
care about
how do we train this and moreover
how do we train this under on the say
some conditions because the translation
system it cared about 26 languages 20 26
language pairs so you can kind of I
think you can kind of see how many data
is involved how long the training
process would be here
so in that in that respect we're going
to talk about data parallelism or
parallelism but also we care about test
run
if you go to translate.google.com man
you type your query you expect your
translation what is it between the
second maybe within 100 milliseconds you
don't want to wait for 15 minutes so
we're also going to talk about fast
translation how do we
how do we make fast inference
but the first in the first part I wanted
to to fold a little bit on work to Veck
because I think as soon as you you go
into natural image processing you're
immediately her about word to Veck who
here has heard about word back to before
yeah a lot of hands so they got this
clear for the for that for the purposes
and for that for the purpose of this
talk we're going to assume that someone
gives you a library of work vectors
because what happens is that we have
language we have works and at the Python
code I showed you for for these neural
nets or these recurrent neural networks
they work on vectors so how do we go
from an English word to a vector and for
the purposes you can assume that someone
else did that for you and now we have a
library we have a library we can look up
every words we could say hey what is the
vector for both we can look at the table
and get a vector for boats what is the
vector for Beijing and we can look at
the table who Beijing but a fun thing
about these vectors is that there's kind
of a semantic relation the vector for
China and a vector for Beijing has kind
of the same difference different effect
different vector then Turkey and Ankara
or in Greece and Athens or holding the
Warsaw these vectors have also
say they do also do plural of here so
man a woman or uncle an aunt or king and
queen they have the same they have the
same say constellation in the in the
vector space or the same if you care
about linear algebra the difference
vector has the same direction so King
and queens and kings and kings and Queen
Queens again this is a clickable link so
if you're interested it's outside the
scope of this talk but if you in
training your own word vectors you can
click this and and train your own word
factors usually this perpetual are
trained on corpora like all of Wikipedia
or all
novels or all articles of The Wall
Street Journal and people turned it for
you and you can use their vectors
but now more about training how do we
train this neural networks well the
exact weights they are being trained
with gradient descent with
backpropagation
whereas a video with gradient descent
and back propagation
but because we have so much data what we
can do is that we can paralyze paralyze
our training over different data buckets
so
let's say let's say we have 10 million
we have a data set of 10 million
sentence pairs so we have 10 million
tuples of other English sentence and a
French sentence now what you can also
what we do in here what I propose in
here is to split this data up over say
10 buckets so now you can have 10
parallel models training on say a
million
on say a million a sentence pairs
this nor network are claimed by a
gradient descent so what you can do if
we have a parameter server capturing all
the parameters over on your left so we
sent parameters to a bucket and we get
the gradient back and we can we we just
update our parameters with our gradients
um if you do this in synchronously for
implementation details you can do this a
synchronously and that gives us a huge
advantage because if we do a
synchronously we are robust to errors in
the different buckets let's say one of
my 10 buckets has an error or it feels
to return parameters then I can still
continue to Train on the other nine
buckets
so I can paralyze my data over different
buckets
another option is to look at model
parallelism
for
model parallelism
what we do is
the compute the equations I shared think
of the show.you the equations that
govern our neural network are mostly
matrix multiplies a lot of them are are
made in multiplies and we can do them on
the CPU and we can do them on the GPU
so what you care about model parallelism
is can we align all this calculation in
a certain way so that we can paralyze
our model to give you like one example
is we have an encoder of the
an encoder of the recurrent neural nets
and a decoder so if we put the encoder
on one GPU and a decoder on the other on
a GPU they can run in parallel because
the encoder processes a sentence it
pipes data to DES
so one GPU encodes the symptoms and it
can pipe data to the other GPU with us
decoding but right away the encoder can
start on a new batch so they run in
parallel
we are doing deep learning in here so we
can stack this recurrent on that to any
arbitrary depth
we can also paralyze that let's say we
have a recurrent on that of eight layers
Google Translate used eight layers of
rigor no nuts we can run our first layer
on one GPU a second layer another GPU
and third layer on the GPU so that is
what model parallelism cares about you
can paralyze your model over different
Hardware types in order to have it train
faster I
don't want to scare you with this part
if you're interested in this kind of
engineering problems you can paralyze a
model for yourself I also want to add
that if you use a lab we like tensorflow
it will do it for you so as soon as you
fire up the session and you run TF that
says that run initialize all variables
that tend to flow under the hood will
say allocate the hardware resources for
you
so that's about
model parameter
the final the final oh
I kind of switched like senior so the
final the final the final topic in our
conversation is going to be about fast
inference we discussed we motivated
recurrent neural network works we
discussed our record no network work we
discussed how we can train recurrent
neural network for machine translation
and finally we care about fast
translation if you go to Google
Translate you don't want to wait for 50
minutes you want it now
one thing to do that in the end under
the main trick how we are using is
quantization all the operations I show
so far were floating point operations
but we might as well frame them as
integer operations which can be run way
faster which can be run way more
efficient so that is where quantization
comes in we have we have said that the
weight matrices and the states in our in
our network they are all floating points
and if we quantize them as integers then
inference goes way faster
more specifically if you look at the
implementation are by Google for a
machine machines relation system what
they did is that they quantized all the
states of the network into 8 bits
into a bit integers and they quantized
all the matrices and and say the
calculation of activation functions they
quantize it to 16 bits and
and that will give us
and in that way we can run
inference way faster we can look at the
training and see it doesn't hurt us much
so in here you see the blue line which
is the normal training and the red line
which is the quantized training and
there they're there to say we we train a
neural network
but the fun thing is that for inference
we get all of this for time speed up so
by using the TPU uses
in the quantized integers and the CPU
uses the flow in the CPU and GPU use
floating-point operations we almost get
this for time speed-up
for just just to make it clear blue and
lock effects see our performance metrics
in in translation so blue is the number
you want to have high perplexities
number you want to have low you see that
the TPU as opposed to receiving GPU they
kind of achieved the same score they
have the same blue score they have the
same perplexity score yet if you look at
recording time there's a portal speed up
critical people will notice one thing in
this table and in this table are CPR
GPUs are actually slower than CPUs that
goes again common notice because this is
matrix multiply so why should a GPU be
faster and that is because in the
decoding especially once you decode it
in production this we have this
attention model going on and that
attention model includes like a
non-trivial amount of i/o between a
given GPU and the host and therefore for
production decoding the GPU actually
gives a slow down world improvement at
the dilution from this table is if you
use quantized integers as opposed to
floats we get this for time speed-up
so to to conclude the talk we motivated
natural language processing and we said
hey what is deep learning doing there we
kernel networks form the backbone of
many of these algorithms so we discussed
it and also the sequence to sequence
layout because our input sentence might
be of different lengths on output
sentence now we discuss how do we train
them we use these word vectors we train
them
we train them fast using data
parallelism or parallelism and for
interim inference we can quantize our
states in order to speed up the
translations
there was my talk I'm happy to take
questions
[Applause]